hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space 2 okay we're back
aboard the Shimura which means bad
things bad things about now all over the
place
I wonder what happened to the cleanup
crew I don't know who the hell needs a
whole roll of toilet paper to wipe their
ass but I'm going to kick their ass if I
ever find them this is the fifth week
and row that some jackass has clogged
the toilets in here we're in space for
crying out loud this plumbing gets
jacked someone has to spacewalk and get
a helmet full of crap to clean it off
knock it off yeah well that seems like
the least of your problems
oh no it's a bathroom who are no aah Oh
nothin
okay voices I'm willing to bet them
there's an evil computer Heydrich nope
you're crazy crazy yeah whatever yeah
whatever
suck it up there wasn't even a single
monster when you were here actually that
bra was what's Broadway dad started why
are those vents open damn it that's what
I thought
what the gravity centrifuges under
repair ah
airing this should be interesting is it
safe I don't know how it could be oh you
know man
Isaac is one tough son of a [ __ ] he's
just like ah I gotta go back in the
Ishimura but whatevs oh this is where I
sprinted with me like
oh no oh yeah whatever I guess I was the
only living no no I wasn't the only
living person because I there was
there's another dead space thing that
was on the Wii and it had other people
that came up to the Ishimura and escaped
I won't be able to play that one because
I don't own a Wii nor do I own a video
capture device so you'll just have to
make do with this oh this is where this
is the elevator I ran into
hmm huh what you want some didn't think
so
whoa is that all right there Isaac
freaking out man man you think when
people would come on the ship and go
there is blood and goop and weird a
pulsating alien stuff everywhere
maybe we should blow this ship off but
now now that'd be too simple
okay got the five I need to upgrade the
plasma cutter I haven't gotten like a
single damaged one that'll do Pig
that'll do I got plenty of ammo for that
only just a smidgen of ammo the other
one huh who's there
I don't like this - why Oh a good job
with the taping there yeah great
how's that sound like a snarl
all this biohazard stuff and no one
thought to ask where did it come from
okay whatever I I knew the computer was
gonna start going crazy it's just how it
is I don't like this [ __ ] as someone
wrote unceremoniously on the walls
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I don't even understand
how the Ishimura survived didn't didn't
Isaac throw like a huge chunk of rock
into the planet where no I thought
didn't the rock pull the ship down with
it or I don't think the ship would have
survived being that close but I don't
know I don't
well I know it was a silly engineer I
don't know jack doodlee ah no does tape
no no one did yes yeah okay
sounds good to me you're crazy okay
so going this way not scared at all
Hoopa dear b'doop
he's gone away Oh get out of here Skype
not right now recording I'm totally
being not scared at anything oh look at
me go I'm such a badass
what's this oh yeah the way with that
wine racks hell yeah hell to the user oh
yeah oh this is the tram area it's like
is where the tram was hello no hi ru how
about some faces and warmth right in the
shoulder
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no no come on
got ya come on how much do you need
there we go God golly that took forever
it wasn't even a black one who's this
normal one and I even upgraded Mike
whatever any more health packs yes I do
okay okay brave and one else wants step
oh yeah
give me that whatever it is all look
more cooties laid out for me to grab I'm
so brave
oh nothing oh hello watch this
yeah oh line Rach
let me try the all fire one point point
point point kaboom
ah didn't work ah I thought it was out
of that I get back Hongki cat why didn't
I just use the detonator from the
beginning diamond wasn't even a black
one ah
Oh take that that's kind of a waste on
guy's leg arm ample Persia win yeah yeah
oh that is too cool
Oh your black one
ah can't see you give me that and right
in your face
to see down
go pro so good at this game on the best
mmm I
one of my buddies keeps messaging me
it's okay oh my god time um ma'am I'm
I'm on the fighting monsters and baddies
everywhere I go all here's the state hi
no I said no hello love me a power node
okay at this lead hacking buses I don't
even know of this could qualify as
hacking for hot-wiring
bring me a tougher minigame okay who's
up there who is knocking down roles
it is definitely safe when I morass on
line I make everywhere I go safe with my
bullets and destruction still hear that
roar that growl
okay
the engineering tech has not completed
I mean contamination I don't think
anywhere on the ship has completed final
cleanup and decontamination at that star
where the thingy that's not what I
wanted but okay I guess I'll save now if
you want me to I will save
alright okay diamond 25 grand
yeah yeah Oh something I want to do I
don't I'm not in love with a javelin gun
just saying that right now
so I I'm gonna try the other only other
gun that I have not tried yet I think
which is the rivet gun they're a model
that I could buy nope looks like just
the rivet gun okay
sure why not and rivet and set that no
let's see Rachelle's rivet bolts
oh they stack up to 30 is it like a
little machine pistol I do have some in
my store right yeah I'll only five Oh
they're cheap they're cheap it's hell
alright do I have any med packs just the
one move that over boy bed bear Wow I
bought way too much okay at least I'll
get a good use out of it I'm gonna keep
that stay suspect because I think I
think when I tried to stasis a guy use
one and I should probably keep them with
me other than that I just need plasma
but just enough to fill out the stack
and we're good alright let's get going
I got monsters to kill where's the
four-year okay that way
tada elevator why is this container
locked again containers are just locked
over and over again hello babies
material analysis uh-huh findings
relating to this legislate material
found I could name several off the top
of my head that make sense
we animates in the presence of a marker
signal ah the only conclusion we can
come to us at the end you mean a marker
was infected and reconstructed and then
fell into a soupy DNA
a soupy DNA sludge well if oh that would
make a lot of sense because if they
rebuilt a marker here out of the stuff
from his head then when they brought the
Ishimura back that's where the infection
could have come from any of their know
all locked whatevs
whatevs man I totes don't care
totes man let's see maybe maybe there's
some cursory enhancement I could do to
the rivet gun just to give it a little
more pep nope yep tup bend your first
one on an empty well screw that what is
even the old fire I don't know something
about someone said something about it
exploding oh no that's the
decontamination chamber bring it on ah s
you in the corner just work last time
bring it [ __ ] up
I got a rivet gun the perfect weapon
anybody anybody want to step
well that was uneventful a whole lot of
nothing ha ha ha
oh please didn't even scare me okay
anyway that's all the time I got for
this episode thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I will see you
you in the next part bye bye